hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
attacking game out of the French defense
to share with you this is a game from
the 2011 airlot open on the white end
got hamsky playing against ding Lin we
have a classical
French E5 signals the steinet
variation there are a lot of pins in
this game I've lost track of how many
there are and there are of others that
are right around the corner from
happening in this one if you happen to
be a teacher trying to emphasize pins to
one of your students this is an
excellent game that's really the one
tactic that sticks out anyhow pins aside
where do we go from
here these next several moves are going
to be centered around White Center White
will support these pawns and black will
try to undermine White Center so as I
play through these moves you may be
curious the strength of the players for
this game csky rated
2730 and the 18-year-old ding Lin rated
2628 and it would only be uh less than 2
years before dingler in would finally
crack 2700
himself so here we are nine moves in
nearly maximum attention on these two
points from here it is G3
now before viewing this game when I saw
G3 I didn't think much about it Beyond
oh White's preparing to fan ketto but
after viewing this game I see things a
bit differently now once F6 is in E6 is
sensitive so don't sleep on Bishop
H3 as a move also take note of this
Knight it's now unprotected Ed as play
sharpens we're going to see that these
Details
Matter from here Queen B6 some attack
and defense of
B2 tension is released on E5 white is in
no position now to take towards the
center the Knight
hangs also not a great idea here not the
best idea for white to take with the
Knight because we would be exchanging
white would be exchanging his third
ranked Knight or Black's second ranked
Knight and this guy is Happy has at
least a legal move now so in the game it
is D takes
E5 and with that we have a shift with
the structure got an extra Pawn for
black on the queen side Rook d8
supporting a D4 advance in comes Bishop
H3 Pop Quiz how would you respond to
White's last move feel free to pause the
video okay dingler in says go ahead take
that pawn plays in the
center this guy on E6 is
poison so in the game Bishop F2 is
played what's the story if white takes
this pawn and says check
how is it that black is doing so well
here well now there's there would be
more than one problem for white to solve
still have to do something about the
bishop on E3 and this guy on E6 the
other Bishop is on a vulnerable
Square it's tactically
vulnerable so if now white backs off for
instance there is Knight D takes
E5 two problems
Bishop is hit and the unprotected Knight
on F3 is hit watch out there might be a
fork Knight takes Knight Bishop takes
Bishop this is considered a winning
position for
black the bishop also is there just in
time to stop a followup Fork if I had to
guess if this game played out from here
the piece that's going to walk away from
this game with the
MVP this guy here the unopposed light
Square Bishop
look at all of these light square holes
in White's
Camp all right in this game the bishop
goes back to F2 straight away if you're
wondering why doesn't white maybe first
capture on D4 I believe black benefits a
bit more with these pawns being
exchanged C5 does open up for multiple
pieces and who knows maybe bishop B4 can
be a
move Bishop F2 in this game black
continues to press with the D- Pawn same
story here if the capture there'd be two
problems vulnerable Bishop problem on E2
in the game Knight
C1 now black defends on E6
directly and from here B3 is played
taking on D3 there's a problem there's a
pin now you wouldn't be able to take
advantage of it straight away with C3
because there's also a pin here but what
black can play is Queen A6 and now next
up there's
C4 and the pin piece will soon be one
for instance Bishop F1 C4 Gonzo
Knight in this game
B3 Queen a six more than one thing
happening with this move I think it's a
good idea to think about more than one
thing with a queen move the
multi-purpose piece what's happening
direct defense of the
pawn gets out of the way the B Pawn so
it can advance so the bishop can develop
and there's
also another pin The Rook is unprotected
on A1 we see this after A4 black can
play
B5 don't take you lose the
Rook from here
castles and now Bishop B7 is there a
better diagonal for the light Square
Bishop white defends the rook and is now
ready to open the a file what black
would like to get in is a connected past
Pawn so something like this but if you
play C4 here
it gets broken down straight away
capture on B5 and C4 this file opens up
for
white what is Black's play then he goes
with V4 he's trying to carve out a
square for the
Knight black would love to see this
capture Knight gets into B4 it's just an
bonus that it comes with Tempo the big
thing here is that the Knight is stable
and the D Pawn really feels like a
connected past Pawn
now so white plays with
C4 Knight A5 threatens the Knight
restricts this Knight as
well the Knight is
defended and where do we go from here
what would be your plan what would be
your next move or two in this position
feel free to pause the
video okay in this game we have Knight
takes C4
a knight sacrifice for two pawns you
know when I made my first pass or two
through this game I did think to myself
yeah that's a a sacrifice but I'm not so
sure it's a a sacrifice the more I look
at it it's not that great of an
imbalance when you factor in that these
guys are now all past so you've given up
a knight you have two pawns as
compensation but these aren't just any
ordinary
pawns they're past pawns and there's
added value
there from here
F5 black
takes if you don't take F6 can be a
disruptive move to your king position he
takes is okay inviting the bishop on
this pawn queen
D5 Bishop takes
D3 and C4
uh there is a pin here on this Knight
and F3 don't go too far the queen gets
to H1 and then H2 King side is going to
collapse in a blink if the F3 Knight
moves Bishop
B1 black keeps the queen on Queen is
hit she goes to E1 clears the way for
The Rook to
contribute
now Knight G6 what's considered best
here for white is to capture the Knight
not the move played um it's a it's a
pretty difficult decision for white to
to make here I think this bishop is a uh
feels like at least a very feels like
it's at least going to be a very
important
defender of these connected past
pawns uh this Knight is on this this
Pawn in the game Rook F2 is played and
black is able to Simply take on E5 what
if white tries something else let's say
white doesn't want to go for Bishop
takes Knight and instead tries to defend
E5 uh Bishop F2 would hang the
Knight if Bishop F4 how can you continue
it likes Bishop C5 check the king then
goes straight into to a pin the Knight
would be uh in an absolute pin and then
white EXC me black can pile up on the
light Square Bishop get the Rooks on the
F and E
files so in this one it is simply the
doubling of the Rooks the pawn is picked
up now it's an instant mate if the
Knight
moves from here Knight E2 and now very
nice move Rook to D3 this isn't
considered best but it's definitely the
flashiest I like the the pressure the
immediate pressure it exerts on White's
Camp it Targets this unprotected Bishop
Rook
D3 what is considered best Bishop F6 and
then start rolling with the pawns Bishop
does
x-ray uh the C3 Square once you play B3
C3 is a
hole that's the plan here in the
computer's eyes
in this game Rook
D3 Knight on E to D4 Queen D5 this guy
is still pinned in comes Bishop takes
Rook this is now considered winning for
team black what's considered
best the suggestion is to go with the
slow moves for white that is H3 and then
King to H2 reason for these moves well
this pinned Knight would finally be able
to move once the king is on H2 at least
this square is
covered okay in this game Bishop takes
Rook Knight takes
Bishop okay we get the exchange right
back there is still a pin on the
knight from here activate the Rook it's
the only piece that wasn't
contributing in comes H4 C3 Queen D3
both Knights are now pinned move F3 it's
mate move this Knight you lose the
Queen Bishop C5 doesn't really get much
better than this Bishops on adjacent
diagonals both bearing down towards the
king side Bishop
F4 you can't improve the queen or the
bishops from here it's all about finding
a a great Square for The
Rook piles up on the pins
Knight Bishop
E5 Rook E8 threatening to
take Bishop goes back Rook check poison
Rook mate on H1 if you take white goes
into a self pin and now Queen takes
Knight is available the Knight on D4 is
pinned there's two pins straight to the
king because of this last move Rook is
pinned and now the Knight on D4 is
pinned and the Knight on F3 is
pinned okay in the game Queen takes
Queen Bishop takes Knight at this Stage
White has finally had enough of the pins
I'm guessing and simply threw in the
towel if play continued
how might it look King H2 you take the
queen you're okay in this position
because these guys are way too good
playing out just a few more moves if
there's a check Rook B8 they simply push
right through there's no stopping
them what did you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye